bonsoir bonsoir 32 1984 30 2009 184 km
c'est la distance que nous avons
parcourue avec lyon que voici
et pendant laquelle nous avons rêvé nous
avons rêvé pourquoi pas ce qu'ont fait
nos études et entend beaucoup parler en
ce moment du burn out
le collaborateur qui sait plus lever le
matin parce qu'il a trop travaillé
le burn out le collaborateur qui
s'ennuient dans ses tâches quotidiennes
mais aujourd'hui on entend aussi parler
d'un nouveau terme c'est le burn out
littéralement pertes de courant en
anglais ça c'est un collaborateur qui
perd qui perd le sens de son travail qui
sait plus en quoi ce qui fait au
quotidien dans ses tâches
en quoi c'est utile à l'entreprise ou
encore plus largement à la société
je reviens sur france 3 pour cette
introduction je vais essayer d'ajouter
un peu d'optimisme alors fait la
conséquence de ces tendances c'est que
les travailleurs aujourd'hui se tourner
vers des formes beaucoup plus libre de
travail il ya beaucoup plus de
travailleurs qui travaille en free lance
par exemple dont les slasher également
qui font plusieurs métiers via plus
d'entrepreneurs de l'aquilon en
télétravail également et les entreprises
classiques voient leur talent fuir mais
dans le même temps il ya des centaines
d'entreprises qui sont en train de se
transformer donc ça peut commencer par
amer un travail sur leur vision sur la
process de décision lors de la
communication etc
c'est l'entreprise réinvente en fait le
travail et pour faire un petit pareil
avec le thème de ce soir que la
reconnexion on va essayer de vous
expliquer en fait comment reconnecter
l'homme le travail et l'entreprise
attention avant de commencer qui
sommes-nous cultivant nous sommes des
étudiants en dernière année d'école ou
parcours paradoxalement presque
classique on s'est retrouvé autour de
plusieurs passions avec françois cette
habitude de questionner sans cesse les
status quo est forcément
vous aviez on a creusé de très près en
allant très loin le sujet des nouvelles
formes d'organisation en fait
effectivement plus nous voyons notre
notre entrée sur le marché du travail
avant ça arrive et moi nous avions envie
de dire et fait on n'avait pas envie
d'être des adultes autonomes ou presque
à l'extérieur d'une entreprise pourrait
redevenir des enfants à qui on dirait
quoi faire comment le faire quand le
faire mais surtout pas pourquoi le faire
et c'est ce pourquoi là tu nous as envie
qui nous a donné envie de partir
réaliser nos rêves mai 2016
on est partis barbelés à la rencontre de
ces deux saisons de ses fans de ces
organisations manière générale qui ont
décidé de faire les choses différemment
en remettant l'humain au centre ces
organisations certains appellent humans
and chic ce genre d'organisation
évolutive sans barrière dans lesquelles
les possibilités sont infinies
tant qu'elles qu'elles suivent la mise
sur l'entreprise
absolument et donc pendant six mois nous
avons voyagé autour du bon temps à
visiter une dizaine ford a traversé une
dizaine de pays pour visiter une
quarantaine d'entreprises des
entreprises qui avaient des
collaborateurs dont les cultures était
aux antipodes les unes des autres
des entreprises qui avaient des tailles
différentes des secteurs d'activités
différentes des histoires différentes
mais qui avait peut-être quelque chose
en commun c'est qu'ils essayaient de se
réinventer et au cours de ce voyage ne
s'est forgé les conditions qu'on va
essayer de vous partager ce soir les
eaux si tu pouvais peut-être les
énumérer absolument
du coup sur les dix prochaines minutes
on va vous parler bon on en avait un
paquet on en a choisi quatre qui sont
fondamentales on va vous parler du
feedback de la transversalité d'esprit
de l'esprit d'entreprendre et de la
transparence n'est ce pas par laquelle
comment s'est absolument ça tombe bien
c'est la richesse c'est la super mais
vous la transparence selon vous ces deux
choses fondamentales pour l'entreprise
avant tout c'est une preuve de confiance
elle transforme avec le collaborateur
c'est lui dire tu vas tu as
l'information mais c'est une seconde
chose c'est aussi de donner aux
collaborateurs l'information nécessaire
pour qu'il puisse prendre des décisions
sans information votre décision
on a vu des entreprises plus ou plus ou
moins grande et donc dans l'éternité
plus ou moins difficile d'installer la
transparence les grandes entreprises les
groupes multinationaux on l'a vu qu'ils
avaient décidé d'installer cette
transparence affichée le résultat
financier sur le mur de leur de leur
open space
à côté de la satisfation collaborateurs
et clientes et ça permettait aux
collaborateurs qui tous les jours
travailler le voir en quoi son travail
de participer aux résultats de
l'entreprise pour les entreprises plus
petites des tpe par exemple on en a vu
certaines qui avaient décidé d'installer
une transparence sur les salaires pour
permettre à tout un chacun d'augmenter
de lui-même son salaire en sachant que
le salaire des autres finalement et
c'est généralement cette transparence
qui a accompagné la démarche d'une
libération une entreprise au début voilà
c'est tout pour la transparence
merci françois une autre valeur
fondamentale
du coup c'est l'esprit d'entreprendre
c'est une valeur que dans trophée
priorité tous les managers pour la
rencontre est ce aussi un point commun
en fait entre les nouvelles générations
est en fait une volonté de ses managers
pour rencontrer de créer une vraie
culture de la prise d'initiative donc je
vais vous donner quelques exemples
par exemple celle de ceux du médoc de
cette entreprise de vingtaine de social
media qui a créé le shooting star
challenge
donc c'est un concours annuel et tous
les ans tout le monde participation
course en proposant une idée ou en
votant et les trois meilleures idées
sont financés un autre exemple c'est
celui de cette entreprise dans laquelle
un collaborateur à dc créé une
plateforme interne qui a comme un
herbier interne
c'est une multinationale qu'elle ait
beaucoup de mobilité encore
être un autre exemple de plateformes
c'est cette passe en retrait par chetan
ya dans son entreprise en inde pour
simplifier la vie des collaborateurs
donc c'est une plateforme qui regroupe
plein d'outils qui permet eux qui permet
aux collaborateurs et gagner beaucoup de
temps et donc de gagner de l'argent
puisqu'il a été jusqu'à mettre un outil
d'optimisation fiscale sur cette
plateforme et un dernier exemple pour la
route c'est cette entreprise sur le
coeur est tombé avec la main dans du
coup de pénalité sur la même année il y
avait des nouveaux services que ce
décret 1 de la création d'applications
mobiles et un autre de création
graphique
pourquoi parce que ces deux sujets qui
intéressaient pas parler qu elle était
passionnée de collaborateurs qui on
essaie de créer une équipe mais
l'important c'est pas tout c'est bien
forcément tous ces exemples sais c'est
pas forcément la création de ce genre de
projet mais c'est surtout de garder en
tête en fait au quotidien
même pour des petits gestes cette
culture de la prise d'initiatives comme
en cure en soit c'est l'excellent sur le
feedback
on a concédé le feedback c'était un
squelette pour les entreprises qui
essaient de se réinventer 99% des
problèmes dans une entreprise ils
proviennent d'un manque de communication
et société quels que soient entreprises
jusqu'à jusqu'à présent des entreprises
classiques le feedback qui connaît
souvent la forme de l'annual review
pendant laquelle collaborateurs allez
voir sur manager pour déterminer s'ils
avaient été productifs et c'est sur la
période précédente et peut-être
éventuellement négocier une augmentation
salariale les entreprises qu'on a
visités elle avait décidé que le
feedback
c'était plus un feedback mais un feed
forward donc tourné vers l'avenir
il est devait être généralement
bienveillant mais pas complaisants
constructif et naturel il ya plusieurs
c'est pas toujours facile de donner
recevoir un feedback qui peut parfois
être un peu critique et pour ça il ya
plusieurs manières plusieurs outils de
faire notamment des applications pour
demander de recevoir ou donner un
feedback de la formation qui permet de
prendre du recul comme la communication
non violente ou la méditation pleine
confiance
excellent et soigner les exemples
concrets par exemple le feedback
j'ai bien des eaux prenons par exemple
cette entreprise à sao paulo que nous
avons visités qui avait mis en place un
feed back ou fait qu'il était
instantanée suite aux réunions qui
pouvait avoir entre eux ou avec des
clients nous on a rencontré maria et
luisao justement à ça au volant et une
fois qu'on est parti elle sont les abus
restaient au café auraient dû mais
pourquoi vous restez en fait au café et
l on dit c'est parce que
on va faire la séance de feedback idée
maintenant voilà et cette mer
d'entreprises qui existent aussi à paris
ont décidé de garder un feedback qui est
resté formelle et régulier de manière à
ce qu'ils soient plus structuré et qui
reste mieux plus souple et culture mais
enchaîné du coup sûr notre dernière
conviction qui est la transversalité
donc là on a vraiment pensé que c'était
c'était fondamental les entreprises
classiques on pense quand on pense à
leur structure en on s'imagine on
s'imagine cette structure pyramidale ou
alors ces départements eh bien nous on
pense que dans qu'il ya un énorme besoin
de 3 heures réalité c'est-à-dire
d'agilité comment le faire
comment elle s'est agité en place encore
une fois on va partir d'exemples
typiquement il y en a qui utilisent la
croatie qu'est ce que la croatie c'est
un logiciel qui proposera une
organisation en certes auto gouverner
c'est à dire que tout le monde
appartient à un ou plusieurs cercles et
a du coup à un ou plusieurs rôles bien
définis
on a trouvé que c'était un système qui
correspondent bien au profil de type un
génial
un autre exemple inédit pour vous ce
soir c'est celui de cette entreprise
qu'on a rencontré à rio à rio de janeiro
et qui dans laquelle les employés
travaillent pour la plupart en
télétravail et travaillent pour leurs
clients souvent en équipe
elle reçut l'option de faire partie
d'une team habituel c'est-à-dire par une
petite chaîne i think s'occupe d'une
fonction support l'entreprise et nos
petits typiquement il ya une team pour
le recrutement pour le blog pour la
location d'émissions pour le marketing
et du coup ils joignent cette équipe de
manière volontaire et
non contractuelle dormir très important
du coup cette agilité parce que ça
permet du coup de tout le temps se
réinventer sur inventé c'est ce qu'a
fait cette entreprise belle c'est la
première qu'on les visiteurs de france
on les a visités et les cofondateurs été
très inspiré par par l'entreprise aux
pannes de nantes a beaucoup parlé de
frédéric klose et du coup ils disent ils
utilisent par exemple advice procès ce
qu'est un système de prise et décision
qui permet à chacun de qui qui permet de
considérer toutes les personnes affluent
influencée par la décision prise
j'utilisais aussi les avait une énorme
transparence au niveau de toute
l'entreprise
par exemple il est proposé une feuille
excel en ligne sur lesquels tout le
monde avait vous pouvez rentrer son
salaire et quand les retourner les voir
en fait six mois plus tard vous allez il
avait totalement changé leurs structures
et d'essayer de se réorganiser mais par
type de clients c'est à dire qu'il avait
fait 5 5 cercles partie de clients us 1
6e qui gère les fonctions support et le
co fondateur explique avait vraiment à
coeur de choisir comme leader de ces
cercles quelqu'un qui sera un
entrepreneur donc gros changement et ce
quoi la main que vous reteniez delà de
la transversalité
c'est que plus de transversalité ça veut
dire plus de partage de compétences plus
de communication et c'est à dire le plus
d'innovations ferme absolument il ya un
an avant que tu conclus et au j'aimerais
juste rajouter un beau c'est que
aujourd'hui on oppose les générations
entre elles dans les entreprises la
génération y va amener des nouvelles
manières de travailler nous ce qu'on a
constaté dandurand de visite c'est qu'il
y avait toutes les générations qui
prenait part à ces changements dans les
entreprises et que même s'il ya des
différences générationnelles bien
évidemment c'est pas vraiment un réel
problème
effectivement alors ce type d'initiative
signalisation elles ne sont pas portés
par simplement des personnes comme
françois et moi te dire pas forcément de
la génération y
pas forcément en france dans les pays
développés mais vraiment partout dans le
monde des jeux par des gens de toutes
les générations et de tous secteurs
d'activité tout ça pour dire que la
vague du changement est arrivé ça te
regarde là
[Applaudissements]